[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté une somme que vous avez promis
pour aujourd'hui une recette très fine
oui une entrée ou un plat principal pour
personnes ayant à petits moyens
ce qui me surprend parce que nous avons
quand même des choses devant nous qui
sont assez importants est excellente et
la petite alors des galettes de cèpes ou
foie gras aux fumées de vieux ceps et de
foot il bel et bien il faut demander
choses bien entendu il faut du porto il
faut des sept premières à écouter ça
s'est passé à merveille qu'est ce que
c'est la magie de chance extraordinaire
de trouver ça ça c'est un cep de pluie
le choix parce que c'est un site très
ferme
il n'est pas vers eux oui il d'une jeune
pousse et il est magnifique parce qu'il
faisait quand même un claude rousseau
mais alors on m'avait dit juste donc il
fallait se méfier des grosses sommes oui
mais c'est des bons quand même en
sancerre ou déjà pourquoi on fait bien
regarde mes amis que celui-là il est
fermé mais même avec les asticots ils
sont morts très bien alors on va là on
verra ce qu'on en fera mais alors en
plus quoi d'autre pour cette pièce il
faut des e il faut donner charlotte il
faut du persil alors c'est un foie de
canard de cannes avec un attendu et
après vous avez oublié de nous dire ce
que c'est que cela voilà ce sont des
blancs de volaille à part à brasser les
blancs de poulet
on peut faire des plans de foule où on
peut faire avec vu vos mails en tout de
suite ce sera fait ils sont déjà cuits
comme toujours il faut toujours cuire
les blancs voient le veau un peu il
fournit plus très bien alors par quoi
commencer eh bien on va commencer par
faire de fumée comment faut-il procéder
eh bien je vais d'abord essuyé nettoyer
le lieu le 7
parce qu'on ne l'a pas non on ne veut
pas on racle que la queue mais le dessus
on les suit bien raconter ça jamais
l'armée laisse jamais rien comme de
pauvres comme un champignon
on essuie il passe seul bon quand tu es
là que là que vous l'avez en hollande
avec la terre non non non non après la
france occupée
alors là je vais me le coup créé voilà
couteau dans le monde dans mon prono où
je vais faire dans la cas seront dans
l'action je vais faire le fut mais non
je vous suis tombé
voilà alors je vais couper monde s'est
regardé comme il est bon oui là un bon
vieux gros loup et voilà les jolis
morceaux
oui il est voué à votre avis je suis sûr
pas du tout vers eux mais pas du tout
une première chose je vous ai dit voilà
doit y avoir bientôt assez je crois
c'est les priver
oui oui on va en parler c'est bon il y
avait quoi vous allez le bouillet alors
qu'ils imaginent convard avec londres
fumée mais non bouillon fait c'est le
bouillant c'est le brillant parce que
c'est de ce bouillon qu'est-ce que vous
avez mis des deux là il ya un ans de vos
wii du bouillie de babeuf voilà le voyez
de beurre et une cote de 2 porte sa
viande des légumes poireaux carottes
navets et vous l'avez depuis combien de
temps il faut que sa cuisse et pas 2 à
12 heures comme c'est un bouillon déjà
avoir consenti alors seul arrêt aux
allées pour avril bouillon pas très peu
parce qu'il salle adhérents la vieille
femme voilà en réduisant le chercher le
mot oui voilà alors je mets vent
bouillon là dessus juste pour couvrir
les champignons et après vous allez
gentiment me faire passer le porto à je
vais y mettre du port on voit là bas
même avalé la bouteille ou venant
notamment vers un verre en vers verdonck
prover de louche en verre de porto
je vais me mettre une louche jeu pour
trouver maintenant un verre avère bien
plein il a envoyé par adel un bon verre
de porto là et on s réduire tout ça
c'est tout un peu de poivre pour vous
gâter un peu là et a découvert terminé
dix fruits à découvert
il faut que ça vous on va laisser
vieillards femmes et leurs biens en bon
il faut que cette quantité de sauce il
faut qu'il y en ait à faire de tout ça
il faut que ce soit réduit et que ça et
pc se pousse c'est pas une question de
temps c'est une question de voir un de
regarder ça deviendra pendant ce temps
on va pouvoir préparer le fond des
galettes exactement c'est là que le foie
gras vins intervenir peut-être oui mais
tout de suite on va commencer par le
blanc de poulet très bien alors qu est
ce qu on va le moulinet vannes moulinet
oui vous voulez que je tourne la machine
à rouler si elle veut bien marché on ne
sait jamais avec les choses là
et ça va me donner des six campings
c'est bon c'est bon et bien très bien on
va tous ces retombées gaspillons pas la
ferraille et je vais mettre ce bla ici
oui je vais casser les oeufs alors les
antilles maintenant je vais m
contrairement le jour le blog non bien
le blanc de bülach je vais mettre le
blâme dans la ruine
ça c'est pour lier les jeunes font
d'autres choses pour cette quantité à
vous allez en être 2003 il n'est pas
tombé en amour vous êtes assis ici il
faut pas voir le curé
voilà 2 et 3 3 3 1 pour cette quantité
voyons propice à peu près 8 secondes et
je parie qu'après ça c'est une fois le
foie gras alors le foie gras on va pas
couper la jolie de marché parce qu il
faut le couper en petits morceaux
on va voir elle pas du côté le nom et
même si vous avez des chutes savez ça va
très bien oui je pense que l'annoncé il
faut pas gaspiller quand même il faut
pas être trop gourmand pour la quantité
est grossièrement
oui parce qu'on retrouve après c'est
bien agréable de mordre la lada dans ses
quatre précédents et si ça qui donne
bien sûr et ensuite on ajoutera encore
quelque chose remettre le porto
maintenant voilà et l'anpif voilà un dé
à coudre un grandes normes et ont dû aux
hurlus mec t'es lui mettez le maître et
c'est tout ou encore quelque chose là on
va maintenant peu de crème fraîche
maintenant vous et c'est tout et pas
d'assaisonnement inc où la voilà et
après hélas alors là il faut mélanger
avec les doigts mais sans ça on le
savait centric très proche évidemment le
fois c'est relativement tragiquement oui
mais il faut quand même que
ne pas l'écraser mais le sentir un petit
peu c'est le don il faut sortir avec les
doigts le bout du doigt et ensuite vous
l'utilisez tout de suite vous laissez
reposer à milan on va laisser poser tout
ça on remet bien parce qu'il faut bien
que ça se mélange et ce soit homogène
voilà là non c'est bon homogène mais pas
écrasé non et puisque ça va reposer un
petit moment je crois que vous avez dit
qu'on avait d'une part notre gros sel
qui est en train de mourir et vire
métaux n'avait d'autre mais dont on va
vers autre chose que vous allez nous
manquer on va maintenant voir la coupe
et vous allez voir vous les couper en
fines lamelles
bien sûr maïté quand on n'est pas la
saison des chefs alors on ne peut pas
faire cette recette mais si on prend des
concédé sait pas quand c'est bon ça va
aussi bien pareil voilà et ensuite
alors maintenant j'ai vu vers lui des
larmes à poil elle est bien prévu
d'échalotes il avoue que vous pouvez
achèterait faire voilà un peu revenu je
vais m mais c'est faux oui on va les
faire cuire la saris sol déjà presque
personne juste un petit peu passé je
vais maintenant leurs soupçons de se
battre c'est beaucoup bien sûr pendant
que ça passe un petit peu je vais
pleurer les petits ramequins voilà je
voulais pas très bien du beurre on ne
fait pas droit
oui voilà lors on peut bien sûr les
bords pour sa tendance à s'accrocher et
l'essec je les entends crédit gamine et
voulait faire attention que ça nous ira
là-bas c'est parce que c'est déjà bon
appel jusqu'au bout que les sept points
dans le coup de chapeau
alors je n'allais pas me pousser un peu
de place la voilà et à la voix ramequins
qu'est ce qui dans les mers de normal
alors gelé par jeffrey morin merkel je
vais y mettre
c'est vrai un peu à m'excuser à l'école
a fait la mère est même pas grave quand
n'importe où à moitié oui après je
prends mes sept
oui une couche
voilà un programme à l'échalote si on
peut éviter parce que les charlottes
c'est juste trouvé par ferme voilà et je
retourne une autre couche là et c'est
tout voilà je veux mais le tout bien
remplie bien remplie et vous en fait
aussitôt un second exactement où vous
laisse vous en prépare un troisième
round temps on me prendrait les seuls ça
ira plus vite avec mais voilà pour les
faits à toute vitesse et comment ce
qu'on valait cuir après samarie au
bain-marie ben oui voilà pourquoi tu me
fais tout ça le mic et il ya une
question que je me pose c'est quand on
n'a pas un froid grands qui est cru on
peut acheter une tranche de foie gras
cru pour faire la recette
oui si on a la chance mais bien sûr en
fait c'est mieux et quand même cc oui
parce que le vent de toute façon
pourquoi il ya un problème là mais bien
sûr vous le fini et ça va être prêt en
temps réel à celle allouée
oui mais ça va plus vite sérieux pour la
bien remplie vous m'avez dit bien plein
en effet de par son timbre et voilà ça y
est c'est prêt voilà anjou it
si vous avez préparer ce plat je
comprends qu'elle est certainement une
raison
vous allez me dire que c'est un bas
marine ça vient ça veut dire que vous
donne l'eau à la plage où l'eau est au
futur ça j'avais déjà lu mais pour bien
vendre
ah oui il faut que l'autre choix très
très chaude puis c'est tout voilà il
n'ya plus qu'à week s'est vite fait fort
très chaud et contingent à peu près il
faut regarder le meilleur attend que ça
il faudra alors sur le dessus et bien on
attend
les galettes sont vraiment bien dorée
que c'est joli
alors qu'est ce qui nous reste à faire
alors pas grand chose on va mettre de la
crème fraîche dans le film dans la fumée
qui a égayé réduit révélation parce que
plus et on va taper la galette tout
simplement avec ce fond de la scène pour
toiles naïves être fait pour qu'il reste
au dessus mais temps et c'est pas bon ça
c'est pas rien elle apporter un peu de
tout le monde et bien le jour où vous
avez ce qu'il faut c'est à dire après
gross est un joli morceau de foie frais
essayez donc ce n'est pas difficile ce
qu'il faut c'est avoir les bons produits
pour commencer
[Musique]